-We're about to play a new twist
on a classic game, charades,
called "Shouting Charades.
Now, here's how it works.
Just like charades,
where you pick a clue,
try to get your partner
to guess.
The only difference is,
you can't use your hands
or your body at all.
You can only describe
how you would be moving.
And you have to shout it.
So, for example,
if the clue has five words
instead of holding up
five fingers, you would say,
"I'm holding up five fingers!"
-Yeah.
-Okay, good.
So, now, before we begin,
let's both put our arms
in the official shouting -
-I believe this is the first
time that we've played this.
Is that right?
This is the maiden voyage?
-It is.
-I'm sorry. I just --
I think that's exciting.
-It is the first time.
Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Only the best.
-All right.
-Only the best for you.
All right, we'll put our hands
in these -- these sleeves.
Now we can't physically get out.
We cannot do this. Okay.
-This is good,
'cause I am a gesticulator
-You are? Okay, good.
-I am.
You know what that means.
-Ready?
-Oh, Higgins,
good to see you, buddy.
This is Steve Higgins
right there.
Give it up for Steve Higgins
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sharp-dressed man.
Amy, you should go first.
-Thank you. I'm going to pic
lucky number seven.
-Oh!
-Number seven.
Okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-[ Laughs ]
Okay.
All right.
-Why would you touch me?
-[ Laughs ]
Okay, I'm standing up.
-Okay.
-And I'm holding up two fingers.
-Two words.
-Yes.
And then I'm also putting --
making action
like I'm doing something
with film, like I'm rolling --
-It's a movie.
-Yes.
-Oh, my God.
-Okay.
I'm holding up my two fingers.
-The same ones?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm holding up two fingers!
-Okay. Two words.
-Yes, I already told you that.
-Oh, the second word.
-Yes.
Okay. And then it's --
And then -- Oh.
-Hurry up!
-I'm moving around really fast
like what you were doing
up there.
Like I'm really grooving
to the music.
-Oh, yes, dance.
-Yes.
-Yes. Dancing.
-Moving, grinding.
-Yes.
No, the first word.
-Dancing.
-Yes, that's --
-"Dirty Dancing"!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, yes, yes, yes!
Love it!
-It's so hard.
-What number should I pick
What -- Four.
-Four.
-Four. A strong four.
Okay.
-Take your time there.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't see that.
-Got it?
-No. Yes.
-Yes.
-You sure?
-Okay.
-Yeah.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa, the reaction.
-All right.
Start the clock.
All right, so I'm moving
my hands like I'm --
like it's something
that I'm going to read.
-A book.
-Yes.
-It's a book.
-Yeah, and it is --
-Hold --
-I think seven words.
-Okay.
-Oh, no.
I can't say that.
Sorry.
-You're holding up
seven fingers.
-I'm holding up seven fingers.
Sorry.
I'm going to say the...
-"Tale of Two Cities."
No.
-No, here's what I would do.
With one hand, I would mak
a lightning bolt on my forehead.
-Oh, "Harry Potter Curse of --
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
All right, all right,
and one of the words,
I would pretend that I'm
drinking out of something.
I would be sitting on a throne
[ Laughter ]
-"Harry Potter and the Kin
of Something."
-No, no, but what would I
be drinking out of?
-Mead.
-No, what would I
be drinking out of?
-Oh, "Goblet of Fire"!
"Goblet of Fire"!
-Yes, yes, yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's correct.
"Goblet of Fire."
-Oh, my gosh.
-Mead.
[ Laughs ]
I love you.
Oh, my gosh.
All right, last one.
Here we go, final round.
-"Goblet of Fire."
Three, please.
Three for me, please, Higs
-Three.
-Thank you, bud.
All right.
-It's getting a little steam
in my --
-Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
-Got it?
-Yep, yep, yep.
It's getting steamy in here.
-It is steamy in there, right?
I don't want to --
I don't want to shake your han
when we're done.
'Cause it's really gross.
-All right, here we go.
-All right,
what would you be doing?
-Okay, I'm standing up.
I'm holding up three fingers
-Three words.
-Yes.
And then I'm making the sign
again that I'm rolling film.
[ Laughter ]
-Rolling film.
It's a movie.
-You know, like cranking film.
-Yes, cranking -- I understand
-Okay.
-And then I'm holding up
three fingers.
-Yes, three -- the third word.
-And I am placing something on
top of my head that is point
that makes me feel very regal.
And I'm in a throne.
And I'm --
-Crown.
-Yeah, and then I'm pointing
to myself after I do all that.
-Queen?
-Almost.
-Prince, king.
-Yes.
-So now I'm holding up
two fingers.
-Yes, the second word.
You're gesticulating
with your feet, by the way
[ Laughter ]
You can't help it.
You're like --
-There ain't no coats
for my feet.
My feet are free!
Okay.
And then I'm --
[ Buzzer ]
Aah!
-Oh, no!
Oh, no, sorry.
That was my fault.
It was my fault.
Wait. Just do it again.
Tell me the second word.
I'll get it.
-I'm holding up two finger
and I'm going like this.
Roar.
[ Laughter ]
-"The Lion King."
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks to the one and onl
Amy Poehler.
"Wine Country"!